let's bring in lieutenant governor of
Texas dan Patrick he joins us now good
morning thanks so much for being here
sir so what can you advise about expect
expectations as far as when we do see at
least some of the businesses in Texas
reopen later this week well like all the
men out there I need a haircut and all
the ladies I know they want to get in
the salon and we want to get there as
quickly as we can without question you
know Sandra the reason we were able to
do this and we're leading the country is
because it's a team effort and the most
important people on the team are the
people of Texas 29 million people who
have taken this seriously followed our
state guidelines and have put us in this
position and what I said yesterday at
the press conference was we need them to
continue we're not mandating for example
as some local jurisdictions are mask and
an hour in our executive orders
yesterday override those local local
orders but what we're saying to people
is that we recommend you wear a mask we
still recommend you safe distancing
because we want to get full into our
economy as quickly as we can we want
restaurants I used to be in the
restaurant business to be a hundred
percent so they can hire all of their
employees back we want all these
businesses to be open and to do that
we're going to need the team effort for
the people of Texas they've been great
so far look Sandra we are and every life
is precious and every death is so
important to every family has lost a
loved one but as we look at this per
capita 29 million people we've lost a
little under 700 people about 75% as the
governor said yesterday a 70 plus had a
lot of health issues and so we're
looking at this and we believe that our
Texans have done a good job of keeping
this virus down and we think per capita
we're the lowest death rate in the world
pretty much and that's how we're looking
at hospitalizations are flat death is a
very low number it's time to get back to
work and for everyone under 50 who have
a very unlikely chance of getting
seriously sick you know they can get
back out there just wear a mask and be
careful but they get back out there and
over 70 be careful I wear a mask and a
little bit longer as the governor said
but we're ready to go get up and run in
full speed very quickly but of course
the delicate balance is the
younger folks could spread it to the
older folks or to the more vulnerable
population and I know you're making a
reference to comments you made several
weeks ago early in the process that you
were highly criticized for that you in
essence were willing to sacrifice some
lives to keep the economy going or to at
least reopen so how confident are you at
this stage in the game that this is the
right move for Texas and that this does
not jeopardize lives to reopen at least
some of these businesses well first of
all we're not telling any business they
have to open we're not telling any
person they have to go to that business
it's it's it's their choice this is a
starting point but on the comments he
just made Sandra that's not what I said
I didn't say we were willing to
sacrifice lives and that's what the left
has said and spun it as Tucker has said
you know that's where I did the
interview as he said totally mistaken
out of not only context but just
misreported and and and could I have
artfully said it better
maybe but everyone knew what I meant and
that's that this is a shared effort by
all of us and and we have to protect our
vulnerable population of seniors but we
have to open up the economy at the same
time we can do both things at once I'm a
senior and I said I said you know we all
need to be careful seniors need to be
careful but we don't have to shut the
whole economy down at the same time
we're opening it up you know I have this
watering hole theory Sandra and it's
this you know everyone goes in the water
hole
in the old days or they bring back water
to everyone well our modern-day watering
hole Sandra is a grocery store and since
day one when this started in America in
Texas all 29 million of us have been to
the grocery store or we live with
someone who's come back from the grocery
store and we haven't seen this huge
outbreak
if the grocery stores and by I think the
unsung heroes of all this besides our
health care workers and and frontline
police and firemen responders are our
grocery workers who put themselves at
risk but we've all gone to the grocery
store Sandra you have or somebody in
your household has and we haven't seen
this huge outbreak of overwhelming our
hospitals we haven't seen this huge
outbreak in Texas of deaths obviously in
New York and New Jersey are different
but if we can all go to the grocery
store which we've all been doing in the
country all of us had been doing that or
living with someone who did and we
haven't had this massive outbreak that
we were all told we were going to have
well then why can't we go to any store
because any store owner any business is
just as smart is the grocery store they
can do it the same way be sure to the
water we've seen we've to be sure we've
seen an overwhelming amount of deaths
and an illnesses in this country as a
result of this but the grocery store
could be a different scenario right
because you can social distance when you
walk in the door they're the points
because in barbershops you can leap it
up we have to leave it up to the
American people and the American
businessperson to set that up people are
smart and and and the hair salons of the
barbershops and all these other
businesses are now hoping they'll be
smart
look people aren't going to go to a
place it's not safe so it's incumbent
upon we as the public to be customers to
get our economy started and it's
incumbent upon those businesses we go to
to be smart and make people feel safe so
they'll come my point is if you can do
it in the grocery store where we've all
been there's no denying that all
everyone in America has been there or
lives with someone then why can't we do
that in every place and every business
and leave it up to the private sector
the difference between the Republicans
and the Democrats and this not to be
partisan if you look at all the states
and all the counties and all the cities
with mr. cone Ian be coverage it's
Democrats and let me happily wrap you
there but I've I'm sorry to talk over
you I'm gonna have to wrap you there
obviously the medical community has said
the idea was to flatten the curve and so
only go out if you have infections and
that would be going to be hairy sir yes
ma'am yes ma'am it's great and we'll
follow up with watching what's happening
in your state as some of those
businesses start to reopen thanks so
much thanks